yesterday the fomc met and boy did they
set asset prices on absolute fire of
course what exactly did the fed do well
first let's look at the current market
conditions if we go ahead and we look at
this ridiculous meaning that goes on is
that the october pricing cost reports
altered views on pressures according to
fed chairman jerome powell now if you go
ahead and look at this there's a two
decade high becomes a near 40-year high
inflation is so high we don't ever know
what to do because we ain't seen this in
40 years 6.8 percent inflation look at
the change in employment
we are down what the hell is going on
not good then also the change in
quarterly employment costs it's the
biggest gain since 2004. consumer prices
are up the cost of employment is up
things don't look great so what exactly
can the federal reserve the central bank
of the united states do well technically
they have two tools they can basically
go ahead and they can manipulate
interest rates or they can use tools
like quantitative easing the fed has
decided that they are going to speed up
their tapering and they should be done
buying bonds by mid-march at this pace
now for those that don't understand what
this means basically the federal reserve
is going into the financial markets and
they're buying assets yes some could say
they're gambling others could say no
they're just simply buying bonds and
they're trying to prop up the market
they're trying to basically provide
liquidity and stuff it in every corner
of the economy whatever you want to say
they've been buying bonds and they say
that they're going to be done in
mid-march we'll see they also will
signal that they are going to
do three rate hikes in 2022 now this is
something akin to them saying right now
we're not going to raise interest rates
so that's clear they are did not raise
the rate yesterday even though
inflation's at 6.8 percent even though
they claimed that it was transitory
forever and they were wrong they now say
that they are signaling three rate hikes
in 2022 that doesn't mean that they're
guaranteed to do it all that means is oh
yeah we sort of kind of may possibly
think about raising rates in 2022. we'll
see
and so if you go ahead and you look at
that inflation then you can see that the
committee sharply ratcheted up its
inflation outlook for 2021 pushing it to
5.3 percent from 4.2 for all items and
to 4.4 percent from 3.7 excluding food
and energy for 2022 the expectation is
now 2.6 for headline lol and 2.7 percent
for core lol now my favorite part of
this entire thing if we go back one
second is that
the committee has ratcheted up their
inflation outlook for 2021. pushing it
to 5.3 percent but the question is it's
at 6.8 how can you just simply move it
up to 5.3 we're at 6.8 so obviously
there is a problem even though they know
it's at 6.8 they only move to 5.3
whatever
then if we continue and we say well how
exactly did the market react very simple
bitcoin rallied from a low of forty six
thousand six hundred fifty dollars to
over forty nine thousand bang bang boys
and then bonds the two years spiked from
66 bips to 71 after the announcement and
has drifted back down a little bit so
ultimately what we get here is asset
prices popping this is the s p 500
what you can see is pretty clearly when
they had the meeting yesterday and they
made their statement stocks they like
this baby you're not going to raise
interest rates right now no problem
let's go back to the moon and ultimately
what we are watching play out here is
the fact that the most important aspect
of the entire financial market the most
important data point is the interest
rate if they were going to head and they
are actually going to hike that interest
rate then you should expect asset prices
to sell off if they don't then it's
basically a green light and they're
saying keep going you crazy maniacs keep
yoloing into the market keep going
levered long and keep making money
that's exactly what the fed approved
yesterday is they basically said you
guys got three more months game on and
so ultimately here are two quotes we've
got one from jerome powell the fed
chairman he said that quote economic
developments and changes in the outlook
warrant this evolution of monetary
policy the economy has been making rapid
progress toward maximum employment and
then on top of that they said supply and
demand imbalances related to the
pandemic and the reopening of the
economy have continued to contribute to
elevated levels of inflation now i want
to make two things very very clearly is
one the fed has officially decided they
are going to retire the word transitory
as we have talked about ad nauseam way
before we started this show since day
one of this show it was never transitory
you cannot create trillions of dollars
or borrow trillions of dollars and stuff
it throughout the economy and expect
there to be no negative side effect of
course inflation was going to be high of
course it was going to be persistent and
so every single person that you heard
claim that inflation was transitory
officially is wrong
on top of that the second thing is that
they keep saying that we're getting
closer and closer to maximum employment
no we aren't what are they talking about
there are over 10 million open roles in
america now on top of that what they'll
point to is not the open roles and
getting those filled but instead they'll
actually point to something called the
unemployment rate many of you understand
how this works but ultimately what we're
watching is there's lots and lots of
people who just aren't participating in
the legacy system anymore i'll give you
a couple of examples if i'm an instagram
model and all of a sudden i stop having
income am i unemployed did i lose my job
did i quit my job how am i calculated
what if i'm a podcaster did i lose my
job if all of a sudden my revenue goes
to zero what happens if all of a sudden
i don't do it anymore did i quit my job
did i get fired is that an open role in
the economy or you can even move to
things like in the digital financial
system what happens if i work at a dow
and i'm getting paid for my
contributions and all sudden i stopped
working there is that an open role is
that a firing am i unemployed how does
that work and then of course even better
is well what happens if i'm actually
unemployed but rather than try to go
find a job instead i just consider
myself an investor now or a day trader
and i'm literally investing my assets no
matter how big or small and simply being
able to generate some level of income to
live off of technically i don't have a
job
but also according to the government
they would love for me to be labeled as
self-employed so what exactly is in
these metrics well you can manipulate
them however you want and that's
ultimately the point if you believe that
employment is actually getting
materially better and we're nearing full
employment there's a lot of nonsense
that i can sell you instead what i think
people should start to pay attention to
is that inflation is incredibly high and
people cannot hire for tons and tons of
rolls across the economy well some of
that's because the government gave those
people free money some of that's because
people found other ways to make income
and some of that frankly is just because
as a society there's a lot of people who
don't want to do a lot of types of jobs
that need to be filled